pour les psychiatres c'est une nouvelle
rupture plus grave que celle des
générations
le Bel 18 mois environ on voit qu'en
France des hommes et des dames aussi
bien qui ont sur les oreilles un casque
leur permettant d'écouter la musique
même dans les brides de la circulation
ce sont des Walkman l'invention est due
au président d'une grande firme
japonaise d'appareils audiovisuels qui
désirait lui écouter de la musique tout
en jouant au golf
vous avez sûrement croisé au détour
d'une rue un de ces personnages bizarre
coiffé d'un drôle de casque
rappelez-vous il ne manquait que les
antennes pour évoquer une autre planète
mais n'ayez pas peur ils ont simplement
un walkman
il y a beaucoup de gens qui me regardent
avec avec un air une nouvelle génération
du XXe siècle ça les étonne un peu de
voir le Walkman mais
moi je m'en fouais perdument oui je suis
bien c'est le principal
[Applaudissements]
pour les connaisseurs le lecteur de
cassette stéréophonique est devenu
l'indispensable signe d'appartenance à
une certaine casse
l'image de marque qui le véhicule et
celle de l'action de la jeunesse et du
dynamisme
la sensation de pouvoir se dégager tout
ce qui est autour de soi de pouvoir
écouter la musique
s'extérioriser en soi-même être bien moi
je l'utilise souvent quand je travaille
quand je fais mes devoirs
une invention qui enchante surtout les
vendeurs un million d'appareils vendus
en France depuis un an et demi son prix
entre 800 et 1200 francs
le Walkman dans le métro qu'est-ce que
ça représente ah c'est important parce
que tu vas tu vois là c'est triste le
métro les gens ils sont pas
alors la musique du rock bien sûr un
jazz rock aussi et tout ça détend c'est
vraiment très important mais c'est une
façon de se couper du monde ou quoi
c'est une façon de se couper du monde je
crois ouais et puis aussi
j'aime bien la musique tu vois bon
j'écoute ce que j'aime puisque c'est des
cassettes que j'enregistre et puis je
suis bien
une mode oui mais une mode peut-être pas
sans conséquence il ne s'agit pas
d'éviter aux autres le bruit que l'on
peut faire mais de s'éviter à soi le
bruit et la présence des autres
pour les psychiatres c'est une nouvelle
rupture plus grave que celle des
générations alors ce danseur ou Walkman
fait-il un pas en arrière ou un pas en
avant
[Musique]